[Music]
Hollywood has always been fascinated
with fly one ticket to Tokyo please
planes and airports have been the
backdrops of some of the most memorable
scenes in movies and TV but I've always
wondered two filmmakers rent an entire
plane or build an entire set for each of
these movies it sounds expensive and
like a lot of work as it turns out
there's a place in Hollywood entirely
dedicated to helping filmmakers create
scenes both inside and outside of planes
air hollywood creates customized
aircrafts and Airport sets for some of
today's biggest filmmakers from Martin
Scorsese to Quentin Tarantino I visited
the studio to see how they make flight
scenes including dramatic plane crashes
feel real
the first thing I got to check out was
air Hollywood's narrow body or
single-aisle aircraft which is used in
seems to show domestic flights the
studio gets the parts from
decommissioned aircrafts which they take
apart and then rebuild into custom sets
they're able to swap out pretty much
every component of these planes to
replicate different settings and eras we
can take the windows out we can do the
seaming off we can have different chairs
we can have first plows
this is their wide-body aircraft which
is used for longer distance travel
scenes it was the site for one of the
funniest moments in bridesmaids it
should be open because it's civil-rights
moving a single seat can take up to four
hours on a real plane but here they do
it in just two minutes so they can
easily go from these first-class
Emirates Airline Suites seen in Sex in
the City to to a more low-budget option
like these ones and it's always sunny
right this is great I can't go back to
regular I have to fly first question on
an even bigger upgrade this Gulfstream
which is used whenever they need to show
a private jet it's been featured
prominently in shows like Silicon Valley
and a music videos by artists like the
weekend and pitbull
since the planes are usually sitting
inside a parking lot or warehouse
getting that cinematic window view takes
some triggering sometimes it's as simple
as darkening the lights to make a look
like night time we're using air
hollywood smog machine to create clouds
when a director wants a more fantastical
backdrop they'll put green screens over
the windows which will then get replaced
digitally another challenge is making it
look like the plane is actually moving
camera movements are usually enough to
fake the motion of a plane during
takeoff or landing but in order to
create real turbulence you know the kind
that make your teeth rattle the studio
had to build a special airbag system to
go underneath their planes with the help
of some powerful compressors these air
bags can be rapidly inflated and
deflated to really shake the plane you
really feel it we can make it lighter
have your very extreme just how extreme
WASC is filmed right here ulema
when we film lost it was really really
challenging we had to take out the plain
of hearts and green-screen and put
people getting pulled with wire and
strings and all the stunning people it
helps their studio is equipped with all
the tools for creating an in-flight
catastrophe and with the push of a
button we can have all the oxygen masks
come down they've also got programmed
sound effects flashing lights and a PA
announcement system that the pilot can
use to delivers a bad news
the only thing Hollywood loves more than
a flight crisis is an airport goodbye
all these scenes were filmed at the
studio's airport terminal set which can
be connected to any of the planes via a
jet way they can reproduce any part of
the airport experience from check-in to
baggage claim all the signage and
furniture comes from the props and
wardrobe department which includes a
huge selection of real airport and
airline uniforms from different decades
right now I'm gonna get in this cockpit
and do some fly-in but before I gotta
dress the part so welcome to our world I
get to play captain in a vintage flight
deck and not just any flight deck this
is the one scene in the movie airplane a
classic a teaspoon of a plane disaster
film of course I'm serious and don't
call me Shirley there's something so
thrilling about being in a cockpit
even it's not going anywhere or the
buttons don't do anything I can see why
there's so many a VNC n--'s in movies
and TV shows there's just so many
stories that happen on there but there's
always has something to do with travel
[Music]